[Music]
first of all no one expected anything of
us so it's really easy to blow people's
expectations with the product when
people expected nothing from you
here we are we're still going which I
cannot believe so escalating like this
[Music]
it's great to see the success but it
feels it always feels fleeting
obviously there's a lot of expectation
for this year which is nerve-racking
horrifying scary
[Music]
this year didn't get easier because of
what you're talking about which is can I
keep doing this because it man has it's
a hungry monster to feed
[Music]
a few games embody the underdog spirit
as well as warframe released in 2012
after a dozen years of tortured
development the free-to-play shooter
grew its meager following into one of
the biggest audiences in modern video
games with 50 million players warframe
rivals the likes of destiny
overwatch apex legends and Rainbow six
siege it releases a steady stream of
add-ons and weekly updates setting a
tempo that far outpaces most development
studios working today and that's what
brings us here to London Ontario we are
here in London Canada home of developer
Digital Extremes which you've probably
heard of by now they made warframe it is
also 10 o con weekend which means
thousands of fans from all over the
world will be coming to London we
figured this was as good a weekend as
any to annoy Digital Extremes and talk
to them about what they've been doing
right over the last 7 years when so many
other games can't seem to get this kind
of formula down and I believe this is
the place so let's go meet them but
we're not here just to talk about Tenno
Khan or warframes explosion over the
past seven years by speaking with the
creators and players of the free-to-play
phenomenon we're aiming to explore
warframes ongoing success how it
continues to thrive when so many similar
titles stumble and fall and in doing so
will investigate the complications that
arise when a developer is so closely
tied to its massive community
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
Sheldon you are prepping for Tenno con
it's kind of unfolding all around us
right now how did you get here with
warframe this is how many years of 10 o
con is this this is year four is it I
don't even like I don't know I I'm in
I'm in that mode right now where were
you know a day to go and nervous
enthusiasm we'll also call it panic it
is starting to set in and yeah actually
I was funny I was talking to the sound
designer our sound director George today
we're saying that you know remember on
that previous game we worked on I
tweaked the weapon sounds for something
for one year and on warframe we've done
a hundred guns and that same amount of
time and isn't that cool cool we get to
keep doing that and it feels like it
feels like that's I mean that's how we
got here we got here because you know
the triple a kind of typical three year
development hope it hits he wasn't
working for us right we were gonna die
as a studio and you know we decided to
follow our dreams we decided to you know
this game we always want to make the
game we wanted to make with Dark Sector
like let's do it
let's take a swing seven years after the
game initially released or in the early
access what is it a now about warframe
that finally has people like oh yeah
that's a mainstay in the modern like
games a service landscape world I think
we hit with the with our community in a
way that not a lot of games that other
games have but not not in a different
way than a lot of games had before and
so the build up of these I don't to say
they're just these spokespeople the word
of mouth I think that's why I think some
of this warframe is a game that spread
with word-of-mouth and that's why I felt
so secret for so long but the people
that are in because we keep giving them
new stuff they're just they're
ambassadors for us right so now it's
like if you have a friend who's a gamer
well you know one in four out of the
friends of yours that are gamer they've
tried warframe so it starts to spread
like that and we've never done like a
big you know massive ad campaign we've
ever done anything that would be
on the scale of some of the other games
that you know we love but are our
competition and I think now just with
word of mouth we've got that groundswell
it's a friendly chip but we have a chip
on our shoulder about you know how high
a quality of game we're making and how
there is kind of a feeling that because
it's free it couldn't be at that level
what is Digital Extremes doing that
other Studios are not that as you see
Studios trying this and not a race is
really successful I think by most
metrics you see you know bioroids taking
us swinging it with anthem and there was
a rocky launch I mean destiny even had a
rocky launch I guess we want to talk
about rocky launches like warframe
wasn't the smoothest launch but now
you're here seven years later what are
you doing to other Studios can learn
from or that they're not like they're
even like maybe refusing to do all
success I think is a little bit of luck
and timing along with a skilled team and
I think when warframe started you know
we're kind of first and that helps a lot
right and I think some of these other
teams they're struggling uphill but the
fact that they have to build that
community from the ground up they have
to they don't have the breadth of
content yet but I think it's kind of
cool and refreshing for games that were
in the space now where maybe players are
willing to give games time to keep their
legs under them before they call them
you know dead or they need to be saved
whatever there's time for that to happen
I think what we did is again we earn the
trust of our community and our community
supported us I wish I had a better
answer for you on that but that's how we
feel we just feel like we managed to get
a relationship with our players and I
don't know what the magic sauce is - if
I could you know if I could bottle that
up I could probably leave D&B this you
know billionaire consultant yeah but but
really it's like you know the special
sauce is the relationship with the
players with the broad strokes of
warframes success slayed by Sheldon we
decide it's time to head over to
London's Convention Center as town Okan
takes shape around us we meet up with
two key members of Digital Extremes
community management
Megan Everett and Rebecca Ford they're
not only liaisons between warframes
playerbase and its developers there are
two of the Studios most forward-facing
personalities and considering Sheldon's
emphasis on warframes community it made
sense to pick their brains next
[Music]
[Music]
oh that says a lot of to schedule yeah
good shape
describe your job in a nutshell Digital
Extremes
well I started just community member
it was Rebecca alone and then it was
myself and started just doing the forums
social media I really had no idea what I
was doing
literally thrusted into it I mean I said
yes but I had no idea what I was doing
and then Rebecca I just kind of like
took me under her wing and now six years
later community manager and still kind
of the same thing you know forums always
on social always in the game talking to
people and now we you know manage a
convention we have to build it off from
scratch and keep it up every single year
go to other conventions like twitchcon
and stuff so it's just really all about
engaging the community as it has been
for in the past six years it came out at
a time when like free-to-play was still
a pretty big stigma it was a stigma it
was like oh like you're doing
free-to-play good luck failing kind of
thing obviously we have an amazing dev
team and I think they've really also
taken to heart the fact that community
is such a big part of warframe I think
we say that every single time we talked
about warframe and why it is where it is
now but the fact that us as a community
team have such a big support from our
developer team and they want to do the
dev streams they want to come to
conventions and see their players I
think is huge and a lot of other game
developers do do that now like you see
people going to cons all the time
but I think from day one especially with
the founders access obviously we made
mistakes along the way but I think the
development team has really stuck with
the community as like a big part of
warframe
I love how transparent the team can be
but it's like a double-edged sword okay
sometimes I feel like especially you see
like Bungie going independent people
can't blame Activision for anything
anymore if anything goes wrong it's like
it was bungees fault sure like I feel
like you're putting yourself in the line
of fire when you're that transparent
yeah when we first started like when I
first started like you said it was just
Rebecca and I but of course obviously
six years ago we did have a smaller
player base so on the forums it was very
active but nowhere near like it
now so we have had to kind of evolve
around that like okay we have now
millions of people playing that are
listening and waiting for us to say
something and if we don't act quickly
then they're gonna think we're ignoring
them or were you know shutting them out
or something emotions do run with
everything we do right we are human and
sometimes we think our best interest is
to say something and really it's not
I'll make a reference of people will
know back in the day we decided to
cancel trials which was a huge thing and
it was a big stress for me because I was
Rebecca wasn't here to be my shield or
be my partner in crime so it was all on
me and it took me all day to draft up
like a transparent PSA as to why we're
doing this and what's what's kind of
going to go on and as you're writing
those type of things you know this isn't
going to be good like no matter how you
know how much love and kindness I put
into this PSA it's probably not going to
go the way I wanted to so I spent all
day doing it put it out obviously it
went the way I knew it was gonna go but
at the end of the day we have to be that
transparent we're free to play game this
game lives and breathes on the people
that play it that you know thank god
support us and continue to support us so
we have to be transparent even if it
does kick us in the butt and it's it's
really just a learning experience from
there but I think a lot of the
challenges that I would say that like
come to mind when I think about the last
six years are just more internal stuff
like we are transparent about what we do
and when we miss kind of a deadline like
when we say like the joke is de l'Est
dry like do it because we'll say here
comes a war within this month just
kidding
it's next month just kidding it's a
month so stuff like that like that
definitely gets me down because you see
the anticipation from everyone that's
excited about it and then you have to
tell them sorry it's not gonna happen
and then you have to say it again
sometimes again and it's just like you
want to give them what they want so bad
because it is scary because we are free
to play game we try to update as
frequently as we can and when we can't
do that it's like oh my god is everyone
gonna leave am I gonna be out of a job
like it's just there's a lot of stress
with a free-to-play game even our
that has you know millions of players
people that come to this it's like it
could end in an instant
I have faith it won't but it could like
there's that reality it's been six years
and we just want to keep the momentum
going we don't want to have a law we
don't want to have any kind of break we
want to keep going we are the same
people we wear since day one you know we
want this free-to-play game to succeed
we want to have the community really
Drive the game and we've been doing that
for six years so hopefully six more 60
more who knows I genuinely believe that
our independent origin allowed us to get
where we are were extremely committed to
our product in a way that I think a lot
of deaths are starting to realize they
can be - which is great for ownership
over games of the creator's themselves
that independent self-published I mean
you saw the news with destiny - right
like like the reaction to them going
independent is incredible
and people are optimistic that the
creators of the game are now in control
of it there's always kind of been or at
least from Sheldon's point of view said
like there's this chip on the shoulder
that never really went away even though
you have found success like a lot of
success but like you're always punching
up at the beginning right like you're
trying to make this thing that I don't
know if any of you expected to be around
seven years later no it is it has been I
think that there's so many expressions
for like putting the railroad track in
front of you as you're on the train or
like flying like that's how we operate
you to your PC to your pants you really
just are going with the the momentum the
community is taking you in like if
they're pulling you in a we're bored of
this we try and fix that if they are you
know have an appetite for story that's
our priority and and now that we do it
all we do story we do you know open
worlds we have to keep delivering on
those things so we're starting to really
be that know Katamari balls that is
endless
a lot of things get easier over time the
more experienced you get at them but the
feedback loop has gotten harder over
time because there's just it's coming
from so many different angles or there's
just so many more like each time you you
address this like two more things but I
think just because YouTube and twitch
are so essential now in like you'll see
you'll see game developers spend more on
influence
their marketing and than anything else
now because it's so effective that's the
difficulty that like I imagined you more
than anybody at the company would face
yeah it's how far do I go and taking
this feedback before we're just taking
everything as feedback like we're acting
on everything literally not possible to
act on all the feedback you get but it's
just fascinating to me it's at what
point do you just say like no we
actually have a vision for this thing
that is the I think that's the dream
sentence for me to say more this year
with the team is this is our vision
because a lot of the players I think
have been giving us feedback for what
they think our vision is or what their
vision is and I think if we can unify it
the future of warframes difficulty tears
its you know balance levels will just
make make more sense for people because
there really is a huge power disparity
and a lot of our content players can
really one-shot everything at a certain
level which is great I think but when
people talk about I'm bored of warfarin
typically it's because it's gotten too
easy for them so it's how do we solve
that problem as a unified dev team and
community which is gonna be the
challenge for 2019
as someone who's played Magic the
Gathering it's the same game but you're
always getting new blocks you're getting
new sets you're getting new mechanics
like honestly magic did this first play
yeah Magic the Gathering has had this
down it's because the world they've
built in their game they've played is so
tight that everything they add on has
that DNA in it it's the offspring and I
think for good video games as a service
you're gonna get that satisfaction a
magic player has had for for years and
for working players they get they get
that for seven years now
so behind me the team is running through
the rail jack demo or the empyrion
update as we now know it was showing off
at 10:00 o Con last year they talked
about at e3 this year they are basically
coming down to the wire because they're
gonna be doing this demo on stage live
tomorrow in this room about this exact
time tomorrow 24 hours from now and from
what it seems they haven't completely
ironed out the kinks yet that's what
they're doing right now to make sure
tomorrow goes off without a hitch on the
second day of our visit with a year's
worth of preparations in place the doors
of London's Convention Centre are thrown
open with 10 oak on underway it's time
to chat with some of warframes prominent
community members to get a sense of why
they chose warframe of all games to
Center their channels around but first
we have a press briefing here creative
director Steve Sinclair will give us a
sneak peek at the announcements coming
during tonight's Tenno live keynote
including the team's plans for the
empyrion update inspired by a return of
the jedis battle of endor its warframes
next big evolution while the shooter
traditionally features teams of four
players running through quick fire
missions empyrion aims to connect those
squads through larger objectives if all
goes well Sinclair and his team hope
empyrion will reinvigorate veteran
players uneasy about warframes future
they love the game enough that they say
you know you gotta fix these usability
issues and onboarding or the story set
up at the beginning so that people
understand what they're getting into
better this is a challenge for friends
this ongoing game where we want to make
content there better
players are excited about and feel like
they burn but we also want to welcome
you guys and with the rest roll we want
to get people enticed to play the game
or enticed to return the game you
brought up something during the demo
earlier that I was interesting you said
you're kind of you know the audience is
addicted to new content yes especially
with warframe yes like a lot of games
nowadays are built around that model but
do you feel like you're just digging a
deeper and deeper hole over the last 6
years it's kind of morbid I know yeah
honestly yes I that is something I think
about even today I was before we started
shooting I told you I kind of like had
to have a moment a time a moment and I
went into the the bathroom that has only
one stall and I kind of lock the door
and I looked at it and I was just kind
of thinking about the problems that we
had yesterday as we were preparing for
the show and what we're showing and
thinking about is there enough novelty
factor here because there isn't for a
lot of it it really is more about a
transparency and an openness with our
community about here's where here's the
bill here's here's what the programmers
did last week here's the here's what the
artists have created it's a blessed
position to be in where you have an
opportunity to say how do I get out of
that hole ideally it's through
creativity rather than brute force so
this parts of the show we think are
challenging ourselves not just in terms
of massive production for her massive
technical challenges but creative
solutions and challenges I mean we're
talking about Barry beforehand and it
just seems like it doesn't take a lot
sometimes that's what the brilliance of
the show doesn't take a lot to really
shift and make a big change in a
character or a situation or in the flow
of the show so that's kind of like
trying to learn them how to keep up
warframe is trying to figure out is
there a way to do it with a brute force
open world was brute force right it's
like okay
okay the open world a lot of people will
only play open world games okay guys
we're gonna try that Imperium is
different and and trying to be more
creative and clever and using the things
we have and kind of it's not a bottle
episode at all but it is an expression
of that problem this year didn't get
easier because of what you're talking
about
which is can I keep doing this cuz it
man has it's a hungry monster to feed
and I think you're probably hearing a
side of me that's more like anxious
about the show right yeah grateful above
here I mean man before warframe read at
that dark moment of laying off your
friends and and just running up running
out of runway I guess is the way to say
it that person would be extremely angry
at me right now to be anything but over
the moon yeah joy about this situation
and again don't get me wrong it's I mean
today especially oh this is just so much
love in that room and people traveling
from all over the world to just say how
many questions I just love the game keep
going that's extremely energizing but I
don't know where we copy and steal from
anymore you know there's just we got we
keep it going I sometimes think about
long running in my mo is it work even
again I even think about TV shows like
where do you keep going creatively
within that space and for warframe it's
been break it has been our answer is to
say if we feel like this is risky and
dangerous that's probably a good thing
and if you feel comfortable feel like
you're turning out kind of like a little
assembly line I'm like no weapon no
weapon you know that kind of thing we've
had those phases that's when my
discomfort with what we're doing starts
to grow I mean it just goes back to what
we were saying earlier like I think most
games would be on warframe 2 or 3 by now
I think warframe is also like kind of
proof that you don't need to just have
sequels to revitalize something's right
oh yeah because we want to respect the
long-term investment of these people
before we hit the show floor I want to
flash forward a bit and
that thread to the other side to a
veteran player who for numerous reasons
feels burnt out on warframe shortly
following 10 oak on Twitch partner Flynn
also known as AI Flynn announced he was
stepping back from the loot shooter
considering he built his channel on
warframe videos over the last six years
I decided to get in touch with him to
get the perspective of a longtime player
yearning for something new the following
is taken from a phone call on August 28
2009 teen community I was what you never
streamers and stuff like that and then I
was playing on ps4 I would get into
lobbies and stuff you know people would
be modding their weapons wrong or the
game audion their work written from
because back in the day it was all about
men maxing your gear to survive for as
long as possible I kind of got the tag
of the warframe beginner guide guide
just as time went on because it got so
popular cuz warframe got so popular and
let's be honest if they were really
really really confusing game right so I
just kind of picked up out of nowhere
and I was I was still in high school
right I was like 15 16 whatever I
started doing that so I can't agree up
with this whole YouTube in twitch thing
what is it about the game that makes it
so appealing to so many people it's got
a little like culture around it people
like being involved in that community
and there is usually something for
everybody right so that is one of morons
greatest strengths but I also feel like
it's what a war is greatest weaknesses
because then I feel like they lose sight
of what me at the game grreat in the
first place at least for me once you get
everything that you want from relics be
all the prime frames are all the prime
weapons or something or the formula that
you need or whatever you know there's
really no reason for you to co-op with
your buddies or even to use the gear
that you've obtained for your play free
of warframe like there's there's no
other content you use that gear in which
is kind of a bummer right because you
spend all this time going to get you
know this really cool gear and then
you're left
saying well I'm all dressed up and I
have nowhere to go and that's a cool
from another youtuber mccann me that he
said a very very long time that goda
supposed to do it like maybe three or
four years ago it's just something
that's stuck with a lot of players
correct their uh their time of work
right as Flynn said there are numerous
others like him falling off of warframe
as they run out of late-game reasons to
return they're looking elsewhere for the
next title they can sink tens of
thousands of hours into but of course
with 50 million players the most
hardcore warframe veterans make up a
small minority and that brings us back
to ten o con it's all looks very
different than yesterday so my name is
alia I am a twitch partner and I've been
stood me for two and a half years I
street loot shooters horror games and a
lot of work room what is it about the
game that makes it something like you
said you like shooters of course but
like what is it about this game that
makes it like its own thing like why is
it fun I think it's the feeling of
ambition that I get from them that gets
me wanting to know what I think and then
making this time last year when they
really israil Jack and put the game on
the switch I was like oh my god what are
they gonna do with this game in the
future so that gets me really excited
also when you get to involve yourself
with their streams there are deaf
streams there so a transparent so they
gave you a little hints and what they're
working on which makes you feel like
you're more part of it and I'm
see the finished product in its gameplay
that so few games have even broached let
alone tried to recreate so I could just
play warframe just for the gameplay
experience like a lot of people enjoy
destiny too for similar reasons you know
it's about the gameplay that really
draws me and I'm happy to just get lost
in it
in 2014 I had a massive ischemic stroke
and after that the entire right side of
my body was paralyzed and I lost the
ability to speak I lost the ability to
read and write and my speech language
but the whole just wanted me to start
doing some things to help me rewire the
connections between the neurons in my
brain so she thought that it would be
interesting to try and get videogames to
help me with that type of rehabilitation
and warframe was a big one that I needed
to learn my math I needed to learn how
to read and warframe really helped with
all of those things there are constantly
new updates and new things and warframe
today is nothing like warframe a year
ago which is nothing like warframe three
years ago so I've put almost 10,000
hours into the game and I'm still like
constantly catching up on new things I
took a break from playing for a couple
of months and came back in May and was
just overwhelmed with all of the new
stuff I had to learn how to do already
so I think they just keep constantly
putting out enough content that it feels
like the game is changing as we it
evolves with us
is that like museum thing somewhere
around here Oh down here thank you
there's the mo of that they we're
telling people though killed tens of
thousands of these that's pretty cool
so we're about half hour from the
beginning of ten alive Digital Extremes
about to show the empyrion demo the one
that they were practicing yesterday
working really hard to perfect and this
audience has been waiting about a year
since RAL Jack was teased to see
empyrion come to fruition so these seats
are already filling up and in about half
an hour we're gonna see Rebecca and
Steve everybody come on stage and show
them what they've all kind of been
excited about all day
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
on our last day in London with the show
officially over
it's time to partake in one last 10 o
con tradition every year the dev team
and community members meet up to unwind
and nearby Victoria Park here they'll
recover from the night's festivities
recount their favorite moments from the
show and of course play a lot of magic
it's yet another chance to remove the
barrier between players and creators and
to look forward to the future of the
free-to-play sensation together before
they all head home how did the show in
general go from your perspective uh it
went so fast and like by the time the
42nd countdown started like no-one on
stage was on stage it was just like me
with my sheet of papers and everyone
gathered we all sat down and then time
just moved for it and like I can barely
remember half of it feels surreal that
you've been working on updating the same
game and like for seven years now are
going outside oh yeah it's not just
surviving like by all accounts the
rising more than everyone
yeah it's a you're scared to think of
like when does the hype stop when does I
mean the hype stops when the content
stops oh I know it's it's our
responsibility to keep the content going
and to do that for seven years now is
like I just can't like I think I'm more
excited now because of the Dubarry
paradox reveal with the black-and-white
landscape with a skeleton man riding a
horse I'm like yeah I can work on this
day for the rest of my life if that's
all yes yes exactly like I'm I'm ready
for that next mature face for warframe
because that's what it's going to be is
that what you guys are like consciously
trying to go more mature in what way I
think we we have to make some really
important choices about the fact that
not only is the game maturing but the
players are maturing with us like
there's players here today that I saw at
the first enecon and they were in high
school and now they're talking about
their college and I can see they've gone
from like you know sprightly high school
students to growing into like adults
with responsibilities and the fact that
they've grown risk the game I think our
only responsibility is to treat the game
as a maturing product as well so I think
you're most digging yourself a bigger
hole every year in terms of what players
expect yep that is that not only is that
morbid it's like the worst part and as
Steven ever talked about this last night
at the after-party and we were like the
last thing we want to hear after we've
shown our creative choices to the world
is how it performs numerically but
that's where a lot of the world is going
it's like oh yeah you had 400,000
viewers but it was like on this channel
less than last year and the hole grows
bigger when people talked like that in
it it becomes more a keeping up with you
know the
zeitgeist of looter shooters and it's
just it doesn't fulfill any creative
satisfaction to have to outdo ourselves
metrics wise competitor wise but it's
forced on us in a way that you can't
ignore and that's that's definitely this
soul-crushing part of it they say three
years from now you guys walk into the
office or something do you think when
it's finally time to work for us you'll
know or do you think it'll be a long and
slow process or do you think like
everybody will be like I think we've
done everything we could here like I am
mentally exhausted and yeah it's gonna
be so impossible to define that moment
but at the end result of it is gonna be
hopefully doesn't happen hopefully we
can do something that that will keep
this going in a way that is satisfying
to the end and if that end comes at a
satisfying way then I feel like we all
have done our job not only for us as
developers but for the people that have
cared couple times
I just hope we can be making cool worlds
you know what if warframe starts to fade
what fantasy world are we going to build
or what like demonic world are we going
to build and just make a new game I
don't know like never stop making worlds
for people to come visit if it's an
warframe or not
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]